[Music]
now we're going to put your questions
now on the government's plans to deport
asylum seekers to rwanda to our panel of
experts and to answer those questions
i'm joined tonight by kevin saunders
who's a former chief immigration officer
for uk border force in calais james
wilson who's the deputy director of
detention action one of the groups
that's been challenging the deportation
policy through the courts and sophie
lucas who's a solicitor involved with
the legal challenge on behalf of
refugees so welcome all three of you at
our panel tonight fielding these
questions from our audience and let me
kick off with the first question we've
got here this is from paul who says
what has the european courts got to do
with the uk let alone deciding what we
do with the refugees that bypass several
other countries to get here that's the
first question from tom
so sophie to you first of all how is it
that late last night
european court did block this flight uh
when it had been cleared by other uk
corps that that's what's behind paul's
question isn't it
yeah well i think it's important to be
clear firstly that the european court of
human rights is completely separate to
the european union it is a court
responsible for applying the european
convention on human rights which which
winston churchill helped to draft and
signed in 1950 in the aftermath of world
war ii
um and it protects the basic rights of
around 850 million people but
importantly the european convention on
human rights is incorporated into uh uk
domestic law through the human rights
act and it was the uk's domestic laws um
domestic court sorry which upheld um the
european court of human rights decision
to grant an interim uh measure so to
answer paul's question the uk
can and do decide um their refugee
policies but they have to comply with
the laws that we've signed up to that's
how the rule of law works
but but they they are respecting those
laws aren't they strasbourg got any
particular concerns
strasbourg's concern was that the
memorandum of understanding between the
uk and rwanda is a series of
aspirational assurances and it's not
legally binding so strasbourg's concern
was that if
individuals are sent to rwanda before
the determination of these legal issues
there is no legally enforceable
mechanism by which they can return to
the uk if the policy is found to be
unlawful okay so so kevin what do you
make of that that strasbourg was worried
about this commitment to return those uh
refugees that have been sent out to
rwanda should the policy be deemed
to not be lawful
right yes good evening um
i think the problem with uh the european
court was that
they decided that they would put more
weight
on the evidence given by the united
nations
uh barristers
than the uk courts did and once the
european court had decided along these
lines and once they had said
that uh one of the people was
not going to go shouldn't go on the
flight
the uk court had no option
but to follow suit which is why they
didn't go
um so
it's it's fairly straightforward there
then
okay so let's move on then to our next
question shall we and this was from tom
who sent this question he said
how can it make sense to schedule these
flights before the judicial review of
the entire policy is complete
james what do you make of that because
there is this judicial review which
would you to get the results of in july
does it make sense to you to to have
waited until then might that have got
the government out of of these legal
issues
yes i could even yes
we are one of the co-claimants of that
uh of that of that claim um that
happened at the at the injunction
interim relief uh request in the last
few days in the high court and
absolutely um what we've been saying in
court in outside court in in the last
few days is that there shouldn't be any
removals taking place to rwanda until
that until that hearing has happened
absolutely we don't believe it's a
lawful policy um but that needs to be
tested fully in the courts and i we feel
it's an uncontroversial request that no
one is removed until that has been
established because we have we have such
serious concerns
kevin what do you make of that i mean
obviously the government is very keen to
get started on this policy they want to
deter
the people traffickers from bringing
people across the channel and making
that dangerous journey so they wanted to
crack on with it but do you think that
was sensible they've admitted themselves
they anticipated some legal challenges
do you think they should have waited
no i mean
lord justice singh
uh actually said in his hearing that
there was nothing wrong
with removing uh the people to rwanda
and um i think our friend from detention
action
will know that lord justice singh
actually said he wasn't going to hear
any more of these uh of any more of the
appeals
because he said in law there was
absolutely nothing wrong with the
decision of mr jonathan swift
so
there was no reason why they couldn't
have been removed i i believe that lord
justice singh also added that if the
judicial review which is going to be
heard in july
um and then the result would come out
six to eight weeks later so there's
going to be quite a long period here
there would be a requirement for the uk
to bring these people back
if
the
judgment went against the government so
there was no reason why these people
couldn't have gone in the first instance
sophie what do you make of that and also
looking ahead to that judicial review if
it does find that the policy is legal
what then will that satisfy strasbourg
well with respect kevin that's not
actually accurate lord justice thing did
not say that there was nothing wrong
with removing to people to rwanda that
was not the remit of his decision
he held that he upheld the decision of
the high court which was that there were
some risks in sending people to rwanda
but that given the short period of time
um those flights could could commence
but there has been today no decision on
the lawfulness of this removal policy
and
and i think that's that's really
important that the secretary of state
has proceeded with the policy and we're
now in a situation where half a million
pounds of taxpayers money was wasted
last night because the flight could not
lawfully proceed and and this was
predictable um to answer your question
anna uh this final judicial review
hearing is is scheduled um to take place
at some point in july and that will
determine the legal issues and that will
determine whether this policy can be
implemented lawfully
okay and let's just get a little bit
more detail as well from jerome has
asked this question does this policy of
shipping migrants to rwanda comply with
the 1951 geneva convention so if i'll
come back to you as the lawyer on this
whether you can answer that question
yeah of course um in short no we don't
believe that it does um for two reasons
firstly article 33 of the refugee
convention prohibits uh reformant which
is um expelling individuals to a country
where they may suffer irreparable harm
the unhcr who are experts on the grounds
and have constitutional oversight of the
refugee convention have serious concerns
that asylum seekers sent to rwanda may
be sent back to countries such as
afghanistan syria eritrea
in breach of that
article under the refugee convention and
secondly article 31 of the refugee
convention prohibits the penalization of
refugees based on their unlawful entry
um and the
the premise of this policy is to target
individuals who have
arrived in the uk via dangerous means
and this we believe is also in
contravention of that article because
the drafters of the refugee convention
recognize that there is no legal
obligation on asylum seekers to claim um
in any certain country but james there
will be a lot of people watching who'll
be confused then because they'll say why
did the high court clear these flights
to take off
they were quite happy that those
refugees would be able to leave on that
flight on tuesday
um i wasn't quite sure on the question
why would the why why did the high court
feel that was possible click clear clear
the flights
hmm well i mean clearly in the end and
and thankfully from our point of view
the the european court have felt
differently and that those removals
shouldn't happen until there is a in
their decision on the substantive case
um i think something that came out in
court was the was the um
[Music]
the the point that you know people that
theoretically that people removed at
this point um could be returned to the
uk in a number of weeks time when the
substantive legal proceedings have
completed but i think that ignores first
of the fact that maybe many weeks until
that we're at that stage the
administration of bringing people back
from iran to the uk might well not be
straightforward and probably most
fundamentally we're extremely concerned
for the well-being of the people removed
to rwanda in the meantime the immediate
impact on their mental health and
well-being and also the risk um as as
sophie mentioned a reform of there being
uh refused asylum in rwanda quite
quickly and potentially returned to the
very country they have fled from putting
them at risk of persecution trafficking
and indeed risk to their lives
well we have i have had another question
kind of that relates to this actually on
twitter why did the government choose
rwanda kevin do you want to pick up on
on some of the points there that that
james has made do you have any concerns
about the fact that it's rwanda that's
been chosen at the home secretary pretty
patel
has said today in the house of commons
that the country's been terribly
misrepresented she says it has an
excellent record on refugees the random
government has said give us a chance
what do you think
yes
this is this is quite interesting
actually because um both both your other
guests are
saying that the
the uh flights are not lawful
because of the human rights act which
says you can't send people
to
a country which is uh
dodgy if you like
but the government's argument is that
rwanda isn't like that and in fact the
evidence is that over a hundred thousand
people
from
different parts of africa
have gone to rwanda at different stages
as a result of civil war in africa and
been placed there by the u.n so on one
hand the u.n is saying well it's not a
problem because we've sent people where
and on the other hand our two guests are
saying
it is a problem
so there you are
okay james do you want to come back on
that
yes i mean i think it's important to
note firstly how rare the unhcr's
intervention in a case like this
actually is um they intervened in in our
support um in the hearing on friday in
the appeal on on monday to emphasize
their view that the asylum system is not
is not robust it's not fit for purpose
um and the the the reassure the
assurances that they have been
quoted as giving by the uk government
just do not apply that is very rare they
would not have raised those concerns
unless they felt them very seriously i
mean we have concerns both about the
general human rights record of the huma
of the rwandan government for example
it's treatment of opposition politicians
and the lgbtqi plus community but also i
think really key point here is because
the asylum system is just not robust
it's just not fit for purpose there is a
very real risk of people being returned
from rwanda um to another country where
they will be at risk of persecution or
further harm that's that's a crucial
point
sophie what do you make of this because
the un has
approved the sending of refugees to
rwanda in the past doesn't it
well i think we need to be really clear
on this that the unhcr has um
expertise on the ground it is not the
case that the una that the un has um
supported any scheme similar to this the
schemes where they have been
instrumental are emergency transit
schemes so that is where individuals
have been fleeing another country in
sub-saharan africa and have transited
through
rwanda
usually voluntarily and then often
resettled to another country so this is
not the case that the un has authorized
or supported any similar schemes i don't
know where the evidence that kevin is
citing is from because the evidence we
have from the unhcr which as i say the
home office has recognized as the expert
on the ground is that there are serious
concerns um that fundamental human
rights will not be upheld in rwanda and
a typical example of that is a reformat
of uh refugees very recently and in 2018
the killing of 12 refugees um in rwanda
as a result of protesting their
conditions kevin do you want to respond
there
well i mean we're never going to agree
on this are we
my my information my evidence is that
that's perhaps not completely true
um
rwanda is a country that that prides
itself on law and order
um i can't comment about the 12 deaths i
don't know anything about it whatsoever
so um
i can't comment on that
what i do know is that people
from civil war in particular
from niger have been and the un have
actually placed them there so um
it's uh it's something that we're not
just not going to agree on is it okay
let's move on shall we um so if you can
see you want to come in i think we're
going to try and move on because we've
got lots of people's questions to cover
here
and the next question is about what
happens in rwanda
this is sarah's question um
the government is paying until october
for these refugees accommodation what
happens after that what's the plan
assuming any actually do go to rwanda
are you able to help us james with what
the government's plans are
um i'm i'm not an expert on on the on
that particular aspect on the plans
after that i mean i think it's important
to say as we've said earlier that you
know the the the problem here is it's
very unclear
what what what the longer term plan is
this is not a question where there's not
a situation where we are in some way
outsourcing our asylum system where
people are going through and having
their site going to have their asylum
claim heard and then will be returned to
the uk if they're recognized as a
refugee it's very much a one-way ticket
and the mou is is aspirational
it's very questionable how how uh
binding if at all it actually is so i
think it's very unclear and it's it
seems very unclear as to whether rwanda
has the capacity to take the large
numbers that at least in theory the home
office say that they are intending to
send people so i think there's a lot of
immediate practical concerns there as
well as the ongoing concerns about what
will have eventually happened to those
asylum seekers
and kevin are you happy with the fact
that if these asylum seekers
have their cases processed in rwanda and
found that they do indeed have a case
they don't actually come back to the uk
they stay in rwanda do you think that's
that's fair
that's quite reasonable yes um i i don't
have any problem with that at all in
answer to the the previous question that
you asked
james we the government has undertaken
to support them for five years in rwanda
okay thanks for clearing clearing that
bit up and let's also move on to another
question which we've had kind of
variations of this a few variations of
this um this is from robert can't these
migrants apply for asylum in either
france italy or whichever other country
they land in and then once they're a
member of the european union apply
lawfully for british citizenship and
sophie what are the options
for people who perhaps wanted to end up
in the uk but are passing through safe
countries on the way there a lot of
people are asking questions about why
they don't apply for refugee status in
those countries
well firstly asylum seekers have no
legal obligation to claim asylum in any
particular country i think it's impo
important to note that most of them do
claim asylum in the first safe country
that they reach after they flee their
country of origin
but just imagine for a moment that you
are um
an afghan in kabul in august last year
ukrainian um
in in kiev in in february march this
year your entire life is destroyed
before your eyes and you speak english
or you have close family in the uk or
you've served the uk government or the
british army in some way and
there are really valid reasons why
people are desperate to come to the uk
and it's worth noting that these other
european countries mentioned uh by the
question of italy france spain germany
take
substantially higher numbers of asylum
seekers than than we do well yes in fact
that does the next question is about
that it's from mark saying do we have
comparable figures for the numbers of
refugees or asylum seekers crossing into
that he says greece and italy by boats
this year and also numbers seeking
asylum in countries such as germany so
pick up on that if you can james before
we get back to that that general issue
about
what you know
what the best course of action is for
these people seeking uh seeking help
how do the figures compare
yeah and i think just um just picking up
from from sophie's arts room and i
completely agree with with sophie's
points and i think it's important to
bear in mind to keep
things in perspective in that most
asylum seekers don't reach europe to
start with um and when they do reach
europe most don't come to the uk i think
we were we received 14th the 14th
highest per head of population number of
asylum seekers uh in in 2021. in terms
of the numbers of people crossing the
mediterranean i don't have a figure i'm
afraid for this year but it will
obviously be substantially higher than
the numbers crossing the channel i think
you're looking to numbers say last year
i think it was around 55 000 application
asylum applications um
to the to the uk which which was a rise
but is far smaller than even in other
other northern european countries i
think france has nearly a hundred
thousand applications germany nearly 150
000
um so we do need to bear those figures
in mind kevin what do you make of that
what do you feel about people wanting to
pass through those countries but still
persist on coming to the uk do you do
you understand some of the reasons that
that sophie was pointing out there
what do you make of that
well i mean sophie's right there is
nothing in law that says somebody has to
claim in the first safe country they
come to
on the other hand
it's totally unreasonable to pass
through
six seven eight nine
other safe countries just because you
fancy coming to the uk
let's look at france because this is an
area that is
um often often quoted
if you actually look
at the asylum seekers that go to france
in the majority they are people from
their
old empire so they're ex-colonial people
who are who are going there in large
numbers
uh they're actual numbers that are
coming
from
um
the middle east or or uh the that that
other part of africa into france um is
is less it's a lot less so france is
taking the majority of people from their
old empire now you've got to remember is
two and a half times bigger than the
united kingdom so
you could argue they should be taking
two and a half times more than we are
germany is a lot bigger and a lot better
off than us
so um
that they can take as many as they like
um
but
if you look at the united kingdom
actually we are an island
so
nobody should be reaching the uk
um unless we invite them uh and this is
really the crux the argument
if we could stop
all the illegal immigration and we could
clear the hundred thousand
backlog of asylum claims that are
sitting in croydon then we could
look at taking more people
lawfully uh and regularly from these
areas um where there's a problem
uh very quickly sophie what what are the
means of getting i can see actually i i
can see you waving there james you
obviously want to answer this question
but what are the what are the legal ways
of people getting to the uk can you
apply for refugee status in those other
countries specifically for the uk
well i think
firstly there are no safe legal routes
to come to the uk the ones that there
are the ukraine scheme is woefully
inadequate i think kevin makes two good
points first is that the uk is an island
the implication therefore that we have
no international obligations to accept
any asylum seekers purely because we
happen to be an island is is nonsense
and secondly that there are a
substantial backlog and in in asylum
seekers awaiting decisions that is true
and that emphasizes the point that this
is a problem with the competency of home
office decision making and the speed at
which it uh these decisions are made
it's not an issue with the numbers
arriving and that's really critical in
this discussion okay and let's um just
finally
put rachel's question to you she has
written to us to say if we don't have a
place to send illegal immigrants and
can't send them back to their own
country and people in the uk don't want
so many in their areas what is the
answer it's a very big question to end
on i'm gonna i'm gonna put that in your
lap james what do you make of that
well it is it is a very big question i
mean unfortunately the reality of the
global refugee picture is that the
number of people who in refugee type
situations is rising there are a number
of conflicts there is persecution taking
place those numbers are going to keep
rising probably for the foreseeable
future i think anyone who suggests
they've got the answer to the refugee
problem globally um is not being
truthful because it is incredibly
complicated it requires international
cooperation um but a key practical step
of the home office should be looking at
now in in stark contrast to this
wrong and lawful policy that they have
been considering is to pick up on what
sophie mentioned around the lack of safe
routes what we need is safe routes to
claim asylum in the uk those have
actually been taken away those have been
reduced by the government in the past
few years rather than increased and to
pick up on something kevin said around
migration yeah just i mean they're only
illegal because the home office has
briefly criminalized people for taking a
journey they have no choice but to take
because of the lack of safe routes so
that that safe routes are the way ahead
okay kevin would you agree with that say
fruit i can see you shaking your head
actually i think you've answered my
question there what do you make of that
no i'm sorry that that's just that's
just not not correct
we have a big problem here in the uk
um
and i think james is
he didn't answer your question either
the problem is that um we we've got
people crossing the channel in a
dangerous manner um they're putting
their own lives at risks we've seen this
already they're putting my former
colleagues lives okay because we're the
ones that have to drink them out of the
the sea
and
the this new legislation
uh really helps because if these people
are arriving illegally throwing away
their documents
not telling us okay who they are i'm i
am what i am i am going to stop you we
are out of time sorry kevin saunders
sophie lucas james
[Music]
you